so hello first of all whenever you
organize a conference don't talk I knew
this before but there's so much to do
that you have hardly time to prepare
your slides and then you see you don't
see your speaker not so who am i I'm
Anna I'm coding data stuff
professionally since a long time I
switched to Python 2 in two thousand so
too yes I still remember how this is so
when people come and say oh pison to is
a standard it was similar back then of
course now I'm pison three only and i
work at bubble this is arm language
learning companies or fast growing
startup lots of data stuff we also
learned a lot so we have at this
conference already heard about data
pipelines it sounds pretty easier you
have it starts always the same you learn
something at the conference have a nice
analysis task answer you want to do it
and its mercy ah he's get the data
transform the data opposes data writer
to somewhere so one two three and
everything works nice until you add
other stuff because every single talk
you have for every single analysis it's
just a one part and it gets more if you
um vs all so nice but you have more and
more and cannot throw the other things
away very often at least in production
environments and I'm talking about those
businesses am fure doing it for fun or
help for a single project you might not
need this but in reality every other
week something new gets added and the
others the old stuff does not really get
thrown away we have
scene 2 data pipeline tools so i have to
get into it then first normally people
start with a fist to run it by hand yeah
that's just by justice then you're tired
of running it every day because then if
people like it they wanted every day or
every hour every minute and then you set
up a cron task to call your pipeline and
then this is so successful that your
company grows or your community grows
and it doesn't fit on one machine
anymore then you have to run multiple
machines that are executing all those
tasks and pipelines pipelines pipelines
put an empty slate is good as well and
then you get those this dependency hell
yeah it's all the time I need to intact
because it's um often you have those
cues as it very easy if you have the
case that they are you want to do one
thing after the other ii-if for small
data this might work that very often you
can do also things in parallel but have
to wait that they have all completed I
will take the example of the exchange
rate and the sales numbers you get sales
from everywhere in the world and then
you have to deliver the Euro revenue you
could do exchange rate sales one after
the other calculates a revenue newer um
but you should never and since those
tasks are independent from each other
words at all we're pulling sales here
another task can pull the exchange rate
um you can never calculate a revenue
when you don't have the exchange rates
you should be sure you have because
otherwise you have either wrong you
deliver wrong results which you should
not do
or no results which is better than wrong
results but you want to somehow tackle
this in reality as this is where than
all this ends now you add your stuff you
run it run it by hand and I come to this
sooner or later if you're good this is
just a small part it's a from reality it
ends in spaghetti code you have this
analysis here pull data from there
integrate this check if this is working
great those reports and to make a life
not even easier to survive this because
it comes really once every week
something will be added happen or even
change you should try to or at lease is
what I try to change my spaghetti code
or our spaghetti code into something
handle ever since spaghetti seem to be
unavoidable we are accepted but tickle
how to do this so some tips whenever you
handle data and I'm more on the data
engineering part so switch to this
because when you weren't all your
analysis crab in creve out if you don't
get reliable data from whoever then who
knows what you'll find models and so on
really say you need to good data and in
reality there is no good data or if your
data is good today you want to repeat it
tomorrow it might work tomorrow but then
something changes and Google changes the
google play order ID from into string
and every
changes all the time so whatever you
tackle in as I'm you know I'm talking
sorry I'm talking about those data
pipeline chunks as we split it up into
those single functions is in the
pipelines and make everything of this
rerun a ball as well as infrared
impotency this is not always possible
that you can try to as for example never
do something oh I have a function
classical and get to date of today I
will write it inside your function get
today's date and then dual download
exchange rates for me said be this is
the opposite of an idempotent function
whenever you run it it delivers a
different results right one will say
okay a pass in the date and this is an
input and if I run it again it again
with the same date in the same date and
I get always the same result so now it
took it is not always possible but
really earth try because the advantage
of this is a massive as I will show you
later next make your data pipeline parts
Ethel code of transactional so that
every single step a chunk in this
pipeline is either a failure a total
failure or success don't you could of
course and yeah this good wrong and it
was almost done and the thing that it
wasn't what that we could not take oh um
it doesn't really matter don't start
with this unmaintained
there is a success gives a result back
it says okay or some result or or it may
time out which is also a total failure
but it's a failure but you can also if
you wait for failures it might happen
that your function is just not running
anymore then you can wait forever as
well so i would also definitely wait pay
attention to time out with our failures
but nothing else no no not more
spaghetti keep keep things simple if
this high degree of replacement
independence and the Bible keeping
things idempotent and totally
disconnected from other parts of the
pipeline as of the we use it why is this
important because you have so many
little parts and they also not look
super cool single body of stuff changes
just to hear me okay it's sitting so
what is the worst when you're writing
code is refactoring and because I'm
already you did your stuff everything
works you have those nice idempotent
things in your pipeline that pull leads
and sales and exchange later place
everything to the report that your
marketing would seem once but then
something changes and you don't want to
rewrite the whole system and this
dependency hell is only handle if you
are I think if you can just say okay we
take this part out and if we just just
take another one in we don't need to
change all the other part this is valid
for any code but it's especially a valid
for data because we have to handle all
the past as well normally normal apps
I'll just there for okay server a good
epic turn handles the now how it is
there's only one state they need to
think of often and data or data
warehousing a data engineering whoo you
have to store those terrible data leg or
if you'd save some report or listen
there there was a thing in 2010 that
people still want to look at and so on
it never ends so it gets worse and worse
and this is why you want to keep your
stuff really hell of decoupled one thing
that are many people like to forget
especially when they begin is
traceability I got 40 buggers and
auditors and again if you run those this
data analysis is storing and cleaning
and love a very successful company
sooner or later they are there and they
want to know how was this decision made
who has access to this um that
not fun but it happens and actually the
this never breaks the audit trail is
very good for understanding what your
stuffed us as well so i put debuggers
first and the traceability say okay if
this is only businesses it could be all
so many people are nowadays work with a
pub sub system so they just put
everything to to a message queue and you
can subside and your pipeline tongues to
subscribe to topics and this is a so the
decoupling works a good in the upstream
in the downstream there but in the
upstream you cannot FF for example
several sensors sending the same data
you must rewrite all this stuff as well
when you want to change it if you need
to identify from which sends or was the
data coming from so traceability is
really not only for auditors it is a few
later and say oh this is how this report
or this data set of this result of our
this is how I got here then you need to
invest some extra work but it's good to
have because it will save you lots of
trouble if you say oh I don't know
scalable as we've seen some of those
data pipeline solutions and it can
really recommend it must run on more
than one machine the decoupling is no
problem and i have my cluster and all
this doesn't it's not a problem anymore
nowadays
not totally sure if this is true that's
no problem but think of it one point is
also when it's scalable always take care
that you chunk your data always because
two days in office is only a million
rows who cares I don't need to chunk
today it works in two weeks it works
then when you're on vacation the North
Sea and your phone rings and you don't
hear them something is wrong yeah too
much data when you're in the North Sea
and your phone rings and they call you
because something is wrong what is the
best way to keep invocation get up
because I had this and when you can't
talk to them and imagine many those of
those data engineers of work floated
have those quickly click tools because
I'm click ops yeah they have that this
is really really common because often
when you design those data pipelines
those etl designers and so on you click
click click from here to there and clean
it and it's all might be scalable and
idempotent untraceable and all this yeah
who can review this who conversion this
no one it's a sodium if this nasi was so
loud I couldn't hear so I just texted
back get up pull request this was just a
short text message and then they can run
it and you continue your location if
this was click ops I don't know then you
have to do videos of click this top and
this turban this tub and II as a you
don't want click ups for having vacation
and be the even more important thing is
how do you review
this um so I have so far and got pretty
far with this I insist on even this data
pipeline designing thing everything must
be cold do everything so others can
review I make mistakes all the time so
I'm happy that I have colleagues who can
have a look at it and how can I share
them screenshots of self click tools
this is like a sharing excel sheet
review can you check my formulas so some
have some tools star XM else who can
code review xml this is also know so
code and this belongs to me for her to
scalable as well what's next resilient
this is quite sweet could also when i
started yeah you write your nice things
and normally I don't do premature
optimization I call those things by hand
to see what happens and then I think
always affair as our yarn don't lose
data and blah blah blah but seems always
go wrong things to go wrong the
beginning it's not you so you have done
everything fine but all any data if you
had handle data integration or details
comes from somewhere and those things
have bugs all the time or they just made
it better because often you just
implement a workaround and heck to fix
something that is there dirt and um
so it will always be wrong so design for
failure your own and not in the sense
and I was okay rolling back and we run
all this again is one thing that you
enjoy one two or three times and then
you're so tired because the more data
pipelines and functions you are have if
you have to restore all this stuff all
the time oh my god so try to do things
in a way that their self healing this is
the only nice way like it's relaxing
when I got that old ha blah blah sorry
we didn't send enough events or they are
all wrong and blah I don't care wait
tomorrow morning it's all good this is
not easy but it's definitely worth it to
go home in time and if things go wrong
through no problem it's self-healing
most of all huge point I want to make it
must be understandable because you
understand it maybe today in two years
you also don't understand anymore you've
done on github but hey it's very
difficult for humans to perceive complex
systems if they're running at all the
same time and be humans and this is what
i call organizational scaling come and
leave and teams change and leave and
they don't know that what you have been
working on all all the time so for
organizational scaling to try to make it
understandable and often i made it as
stupid as possible really stupid stupid
stupid yesterday 22 said constrain
yourself to the simple and this is not
easy if you have the SuperDuper solution
set know it's possible but keep it
simple stupid I always say make it so
simple that even product owners can
understand
um that's a bit mean but it's super cool
then you don't have to do the work
anymore they just design some flow
charts and flow chart it says either
things can run in parallel then they're
on the same size and this is a
dependency so this is the other exchange
rate per sale ting and so this doesn't
does only run if this block has
completed but we can pull currencies and
prices independent of each other and you
can draw this post it on whiteboards
excellent and you can talk to people
about this I can move things around I
highly recommend to keep things
understandable there are solutions that
do this um and also quite nice and well
air flow from airbnb does all this task
and Ling highly recommendable Luigi from
Spotify yesterday we heard about the
probably coming yamel from blue yonder
it's just one thing all the stuff if
it's scaling out then yeah of course it
runs on clusters I don't want two
clusters I just want to run some simple
stupid tasks I don't want just a
management or all those highs and to
stuff the salt and and it's not sold the
twisted libraries and so why why do i do
I don't need it I just want those things
to run and I also to the others in yeah
but how do you do this so I don't want
less us and I don't want to maintain
state and if I need to know okay this
has worked and this has worked not if I
need to keep
of what has been done and what not then
I either need to set up a cluster so
those huge extra system to watch what my
data system does and then if this gets
more and more and then maybe I need an
extra system to watch what my
maintenance systems does I don't want
maintenance I don't want clusters I just
want my tiny functions to run and yep no
cluster boom and so yes this amazing
company amazon they maintain a lot and
they have this simple workflow and they
maintain state look loud scaling
horizontally it's a pretty advanced
service not used very much most people
stick to cues as SQS or and even kinases
i think only because it's simpler to
understand philip and me try to or we
are using a python library you using a
simple workflow that takes a lot of the
possibilities of simple workflow out
make it just super stupid so I this
thing is Conda installable as we will
have it running in production we
orchestrate our task so it's change when
sales report generation with this it's
pretty alpha I deployed the last version
you are not as few seconds ago now its
how many 25 minutes ago and it's not a
topic I want to talk about today but we
use flow based programming approach that
we a separate designer from activity
logic and we just want to show you what
this looks like if I find my mouse how
many minutes left to be
okay I worked a small demo for today
it's just there's two three steps there
are so first I get some some random
number and there's also to show that
this is in no way time-based or whatever
so this kit is a random number X and
then I have all those tasks that can run
in parallel they sleep for X seconds or
I can input parameters as those boxes it
they can have an input and an output
nothing else and so this sleeps x times
input value b x in x times input value
when all those are done the same
function sleeps x times input value
sounds a bit um so now let's see my so
move over over over so let's just
bakrid so no more slides so I let's see
if this works yeah this does not work
good clear so whatever we start does
this work yeah so I start a worker yes I
try to i have also debug mode on here I
start where am I I start decider these
are the two things and now I need a
workflow need a workflow one more thing
is that we have written all the stuff
also it's the code itself is Python but
all tasks definitions and outputs it's
yeah here is the thing yeah it's a
worker
so to get the four so this is already
done had a short it was I had was only
sleeping for two times two seconds
decided terminate we said that this
decider is done hang on I want to really
prove that do you have your computer
that yeah you have I'd like to kill this
worker clear that I pass on on a screen
when I am mi
that's better so I killed my worker so
run a decider start to work flow we
never could just set a worker please on
your machine good so let's see I are
here the decider is scattering activity
tasks I could now I close my chrome
let's do more meet at about this how its
yeah but done as this is really you this
gate you just need to start a decider
and your worker functions wherever it
wants on your local machine on ec2
instances but without clusters without
this that you just simple worker you
just tell do yeah start go from the
thing is on github pretty alpha but has
a massive read me and we're working on
it a lot don't use it at work yet
because we know what we're doing and
there's some time out issues and you can
easily make this sort of fail but i can
recommend to have a look at it yo
we are using this so Amazon because he
is just the decider and a worker and as
a decide the orchestration is done by
simple workflow because the activity
work as an activity workers asked the
buffer to have something to do do you
have something to do do you have
something to do then simple absolutely
here look this is what's needs to be
done one task and Amazon guarantees that
no task will be executed twice this is
what you do not want that the timeouts
and sent timeouts and so I decided I
said have I something to decide however
something to decide the worker says
totally independent having something to
do by decoupling this logic and simple
workflow just offers those events
history stuff you don't need to maintain
state and don't need clusters okay so
whoever has a question waits until he
has the microphone or she so that it's
we recorded so the first question was
you I've been is annoyed you for quite a
while it really improved our
productivity a lot so i was wondering
like if you have used some of the other
tools of dimension and then how do they
compare like why did you go for simple
out of us bad boy and yep yeah actually
because i don't want to run a 0 mq or a
celery cluster just to run my tasks and
there's an orchestration if it's on one
machine that's all nice but if you boot
up several and then then the cron job
sent and all this i do it you can do it
by lambda you don't even need to server
at all anymore if the first task is put
up a machine then a machine is there run
this app put the machine down I don't
need to maintain I go home in the
evening I have weekends we all have
bubbling elvis's because we are trying
to write serverless code we don't have
one this admin in the company because we
don't want to sit there and see if
things work and this is just doesn't
move
so I would if you just start with this
do this airflow is pretty nice but when
I think if I see start from scratch
anyway and then all this cluster
management is much much legacy Python I
think this must stop as it's also
another reason we think if I also
contribute to this it has always worked
and this is why we need stick to it a
thing then I'm part of this keeping this
around except it the most is I don't
want to maintain state or clusters and
this is what you need to do even with a
Luigi and even with airflow if you need
more than my machine it's a question it
fun yeah and thank you for the Hulk but
then if you don't want to like em server
architecture maintaining a cluster why
don't you choose like lambda functions
we are this works with lambda functions
is an orchestration for lambda function
no it's not on your new can boot up
machines you can boot up your mobile
phone if your mobile phone with this
want to do the work all you need is ok
Python 3 and 5 here started 5 I think I
know also for and and your AWS
credentials but you can of course just
integrate lambda functions in your
workflow as is for example booting those
things herbs it's really nice scheduled
lambda if you want some every month to
this you start a scheduled lambda the
scheduled lambda boots up as many
instances as you need but this is a part
of the workflow and then it decides what
to do and then your workflow is next
step so I here I would begin with that
your workflow starts was putting the
machines up or if the lambda function
can do it themselves also fine but the
activity workers in a simple workflow
can be lambda functions was super cool
but there are no decide us yet because
this is all so long polling lambda
China's five minutes currently and this
is often really long stuff but you can
do lambdas with it yeah and that's nice
ok so we have time for one more question
I great talk I have one question
regarding comparing it to air flow it's
really nice that in after we have a web
interface and you can usually explain
this to your product manager or whoever
is in the company in the morning before
you and you can see all this has been
run and he doesn't call you because he
knows okay this is already handled by
the system so is there something
comparable with AWS or mr. yeah I
haven't shown this now but as show you
after the top other day is this a pretty
ugly simple work in the console you have
so simple workflow interface where you
see what the workflows and you can even
start work flows from there I'll kill
them and give parameters in it's a bit
ugly but works well so you could just do
it if this workflow execution failed to
sit in the console then start a new one
with another parameter so this exists
since this also uses just graph is so
these are directed graphs we could or
maybe we can convince someone to
visualize the graph justjust per person
it's a simple directed graph should be
no problem to get the state because
whenever they decide to the pipeline
decides what to do next yeah then we
could also visualize it somewhere but
this is yeah we need it but you can see
anyone can see who has a I am permission
okay thank you very much for a nice talk
you